who I used to be  something more  [Music]  it's time I told you the truth about  Leanne Grace  he first came to this house  it was an act of love  that love was a selfish love  it has brought death and destruction  [Music]  it'll keep getting hurt in this house  again  when she's happy things are good  but she's angry things go bad  I'm not who I used to be  [Music]  she scares me  something like more  I hurt people when I get angry  scariest part is that I'm starting to  like the way that it feels  [Music]  [Music]  if she wins the city would fall and  that's only the beginning  just what I thought you couldn't make  this any more disgusting and morally  apart  do you want to hear secret Dorothy  [Music]  [Music]